[vent qui souffle]
Salut à vous peuple des Internets !
Aujourd'hui nous sommes le 18 décembre, donc 18ème ouverture de ce calendrier de l'Avent.
Tous les jours à 6H du matin, comme d'habitude.
Et je vous parle, de quelque chose, je trouvais ça intéressant d'en parler sur la chaîne durant ce calendrier de l'Avent.
Je vous dis souvent que je continue à me former en tant que mentaliste,
de m'intéresser à tout ce qui se fait, tout ce qui sort...
Mais ce n'est pas très concret quand je vous dis ça.
Voilà un exemple très concret: je me suis acheté au mois de septembre le livre "Tous addicts et après ?".
Donc c'est un bouquin sur les addictions.
Et là vous vous dites: "Mais où est le rapport avec le mentalisme ?"
C'est vrai ! Il est où ?
Et bien, ces dernières années il y a eu beaucoup d'avancées dans l'approche et dans le traitement des addictions,
et aussi beaucoup d'avancées dans les nouvelles addictions qui existent.
Et ce livre complilent un petit peu tout ça.
Et il va parler en 3 thèmes des addictions à des substances licites comme le tabac ou l'alcool par exemple,
des addictions à des substances illicites comme la cocaïne, l’héroïne...
et les addictions à des choses sans substances.
Comme les jeux vidéos, le sexe, les écrans, etc...
Dans le "etc" je mets aussi le sport. Il y a des addicts au sport.
Tout ça ce sont des addictions que l'on oublie un peu.
Et le livre va redétailler tout ça,
va faire une espèce de mise à jour par rapport à tout ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
et c'est ça qui est interéssant dans le mentalisme, il va surtout parler du processus du comportement,
pourquoi ça arrive, comment ça arrive, et après les solutions qui existent pour essayer d'en sortir
ou les pistes de réfléxion qu'il y a en ce moment sur les travaux en cours.
Parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a énormément de potentiels qui ne sont pas forcément exploités, de travaux,
ou de prévention soit pour s'en sortir soit pour prévenir.
Et ce que j'ai trouvé vraiment passionant dans le livre, alors les auteurs sont: William Lowenstein et Laurent Karila,
lui est un médecin spécialisé en addictologie et elle, est une psychiatre spécialisé en addictologie,
et ils décrivent aussi tout le processus de l'addiction.
Et c'est ça qui est passionant.
Comment ça se fait qu'à un moment donné on devient addict à quelque chose
et est-ce que en plus on a vraiment conscience de ça
et quel est notre comportement quand on est addict à quelque chose sans en avoir conscience et du coup quelles sont les interactions que l'on peut avoir avec une personne comme ça ?
Ce qui, à ce stade là de la vidéo ne voient pas de lien avec le mentalisme,
ce sont des personnes qui, (vous en faites peut-être parti),
qui pensent que le mentalisme c'est uniquement le fait de deviner ce à quoi quelqu'un pense
ou influencer un choix.
Encore une fois, ma définition du mentalisme est beaucoup plus large que ça,
elle est, on va dire, dans la compréhension des choses,
d'où mon kiff pour les énigmes par exemple,
et toutes les vidéos que je vous ai faites ce mois-ci.
Ou dans la compréhension de l'être humain, et cela en fait clairement partie.
Ce livre, je vous en parle vraiment parce qu'il est vulgarisé.
Donc il est très abordable.
Et il prend tous ces thèmes point par point.
Je vous lis dans les substances illicites:
on a le cannabis, la cocaïne, l’héroïne, la MDMA, les nouveaux produits de synthèse que l'on trouve trop facilement sur Internet.
Dans les licites: l'alcool, le tabac, les médicaments.
Dans les sans substance: sexe, écrans, binge watching,  jeux, addictions alimentaires, workaholisme, junkies du sport, acheteurs et acheteuses en série, les sun addict.
Parce qu'il y a aussi des addicts du soleil qui vont faire beaucoup d'UV.
C'est passionnant.
Si vous êtes juste curieux de nature, et curieux d'un petit peu tout et toujours interessé par certains aspects du mentalisme,
je vous recommande ce livre. C'est édité chez Flammarion.
J'ai l'impression d'être Bernard Pivot qui vient de présenter un nouveau livre.
Likez la vidéo si ça vous a plu.
N'oubliez pas de laisser un commentaire si vous avez des questions précises sur le livre, j'y répondrai.
Et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner.
Rendez-vous demain matin à 6H.
Ciao !
[musique]